(techno sound)
(techno music)
- If you ask, how does the brain work
from an engineering
perspective, then you might ask,
what does the circuit diagram look like?
After all, if complex modern processors
are designed and understood by engineers,
then maybe a simple brain could be
likewise understood at that level.
So, let's consider exactly
that, a simple processor.
And if you take the lid off, you'll find
underneath the die, the chip.
Looking at it a little bit closer
you'll see that it's broken
up into various modules
for processing, for input
from various sources
and for outputs, memory and
likewise in the control.
If you'd look at a small
region and zoom in on it
you'll find it's covered by a
vast mesh of tiny, tiny wires.
This is about maybe a dozen layers thick,
underneath it all there
are the actual switches,
the transistors, which
do the switching on this.
Now if you want to make it, you just need
a few billion dollars, machines like this,
and, you know, you're good.
If you want to reverse engineer it,
then maybe you could use
some machines like this
as one example, which I'll be discussing
in more detail, called a FIB SEM.
Now, on the other end, here's
another processing unit.
Let's take the cover off and
underneath there's a brain.
And it, too, has various
modules in it, you know,
optical inputs, they're
called optic lobes,
antenna inputs for smell, memory units,
they all have different
names, mushroom bodies,
ellipsoid bodies, and so
forth, studied by biologists.
So you can also zoom in
and look very carefully
and presumably there's also going to be
a vast mesh of wiring in there,
and somehow buried in
underneath all of that
should be synapses, which are switching
between all of these different wires.
Now if you want to make one of these
you need to invest in an old banana
(audience laughter)
and wait, not much cost
and it'll self assemble.
And it's amazing and
you've heard about this,
you know, in the first talk
and it's truly amazing.
So now if you want to reverse engineer it
we really need, it's a tough problem
and we need tools from
across the spectrum,
from biology, from genetics, and I'll talk
a little bit of the
aspect that can come in
from the semiconductor
industry, that FIB SEM.
So just to put a
perspective, let's put some
dimensions on these and
compare them side by side.
A current processor is sort of a
flattened structure, two
and a half dimensions,
but the volume of it
is under a millimeter.
The fruit fly, it's a nice little blob,
under a millimeter in size, but not
too different in the volume.
The number of transistors and switches
in the processor are
actually pretty impressive,
about a billion transistors nowadays,
that's a bit more than the fruit fly.
If you go back 10 years, the Pentiums,
they had about a comparable number.
And the last part now is the wire size
and the transistor size and the
dendrite size, synapse size,
they're all in the tens
of nanometers, very small.
And the challenge is to bridge the gap
between the small size
of tens of nanometers
all the way up to a good
fraction of a millimeter
and catch that large dynamic range.
So to reliably resolve these transistors,
in all three dimensions,
we need to sample,
probably instead of 50 nanometers,
maybe at five or 10 nanometer increments.
These are the voxels that
you'd use to form images,
and you've seen before
one can sort of collect
many such images in 3D, form a stack.
But if you just quickly
look at the numbers,
how many voxels, how
many pixels are there,
eight nanometers compared
to half a millimeter,
there are lots, it's a good
fraction of a petabyte.
And if you're acquiring the data at
a modest rate of a
megahertz, then you'd be
acquiring data for eight years,
even for something as
simple as a fruit fly plane.
Now I should also point out we do need
to really see the connectivity
one needs to go down to the EM level,
to the electron microscope level.
Light microscopy cannot
quite resolve the details
and see the fine connectivity.
Light microscopy can do many other things,
image live, so all these techniques
are very complementary
and support each other.
So, what is this FIB SEM?
This is basically an instrument
where you use FIB, which
is a focused ion beam
and it basically abrades away the surface
a few nanometers at a time.
The advantage of an ion
beam is the abrasion is
just a little bit finer, more controlled
in the Z dimension, otherwise
it's very similar to
what Mark was talking about earlier,
the serial block face cutting.
After you abrade, or
remove a little layer,
you image the surface with a scanning
electron beam and then you ablate again.
And you cycle through
this about every minute.
And you keep going and going
for as long as you possibly can.
And in the end, you gradually
reconstruct a circuit.
In this case, if you're looking
at a semiconductor chip,
you can see all the metal layers inside.
If one's looking at a fly brain,
then you should get a three dimensional
reconstruction of all the details inside.
So this here is the outline
of one of these synapses,
the black part is actually
the membrane itself.
Ah, and there you can see.
So what you saw, you know
time here is moving in in Z.
And you'll see on the
left picture right there
the dark spots, those are actually
the synapses, they're pretty small.
And this is a typical fan in circuit,
there are multiple synapses
going all onto one dendrite.
And you see the opposite in
the fly, fan ins, fan outs,
there are just a variety of
structures that are all visible.
It's more complex than it
is for a mammalian brain.
So we got one of these
machines and started out.
And so we ran it, three days later
it came to a grinding halt and stopped.
And so we imaged one one
thousandths of a brain
and couldn't continue, there are problems.
And so we came to this conclusion.
(audience laughter)
FIBSEM's irrelevant because it
can't image anything useful.
I continued to be employed.
(audience laughter)
And worked on the next problem,
five years of reliability engineering,
basically to handle all of
these interrupts as they happen.
Can we anticipate things,
make graceful stops
if something bad is going to happen,
mitigate damage control and we can
restart without loss of anything.
The bar is very high
because if you have a gap
in this dense interconnect of wiring,
there's no way that you
can connect the wires
from the left half to the right half
and your circuit diagram is just useless.
So you don't want to be
there, imaging several years
into the project and then say oops.
So a few years later, here we are,
imaging now for about
a three months project,
that is looking at the optical lobe.
You might have noticed three pieces,
the medulla, lobular and lobular plate.
And this is sort of what
you see inside a fly brain.
This is, the motion you see is, again,
is moving in Z, deeper and deeper.
Initially the width was about 120 microns,
it's about the width of two human hairs.
And in zooming in about 10x
and we can look at detail
and for example right
there, that's a synapse.
And it's connecting this dendrite over to
several other guys on the other side,
you know, it's all very subtle.
And it's a, you know, it's
a big challenge to try to
pull all of that information
out and segment it.
So it took us three months to image this.
And then we gave it to some other people
and about three years later
they processed the data.
Processing it and analyzing it
is by far the bigger challenge.
This is, this is not easy and it requires
a lot of hand effort or did
require a lot of hand effort
to segment, curate, make sure
there's no mistake in there.
And what we're doing here
is dense segmentation.
We're getting pretty much
all of the processes,
all of the neurons, identifying them.
And then you can pull them out one by one
and you find that they have
their own unique shapes
and sizes, and compare them to what
is known from other experiments.
For example, you know,
some of these neurons
are, you know, this is
coming in from the retina,
some of them are sensitive
to an on transition
or to an off transition or to a left
to right motion or front to back motion
and people can identify that
based on optical imaging.
But optical imaging can't tell you
the detailed synaptic connectivity,
but it can give you the classes
of neurons, so one can connect the two
and bootstrap our way forward.
In addition, optical imaging can look at
live samples, too and
tell which ones are firing
on on transitions and off transitions
and we can actually monitor that.
So all of that data can be put together
and you can begin to identify the
components of a circuit diagram.
And these are the three major parts
that you saw earlier,
the medulla, the lobular
and the lobular plate,
up here's the retina.
The thing is with the
FIB SEM it allows you
to make the last little
connection which is to ask,
here's one neuron which we know reacts
to a left to right on
transition, what are its inputs?
And you can define the
neurons that are responsible
for that, characterize those independently
and we make this last step.
And then you can begin to
test models of the circuit.
Is this a coincidence detector
based on excitatory inputs,
is it a different version of that,
a nor detector where you might have
an inhibitory input on one side?
And it turns out that it's a little bit
of a combination of both
are present in the fly brain
and you can even sort of get estimates
of what might be causing the delay
based on length on the synapse.
So having this extra level of detail
helps close a lot of open gaps.
So so far we still haven't
gotten to the full fly brain.
And we reverted to another technique
called hot knife sectioning
to get all the way up.
Imagine the fly brain, you chop it up
into like a loaf of bread
into about 30 pieces
each about 20 nanometers thick.
You put it onto a little laminated surface
and you have about 30 of these tabs
and feed them in to a bunch of machines.
And this puts us in the
range of getting these,
this eight FIB SEM year
effort maybe down to
a little bit more reasonable time.
And we are gearing up and trying to expand
toward this direction here.
And so far, for the past two years
we've come just a little
ways along that path.
Looking in here we have what we've
accomplished called the hemi brain.
It aspires to be half a brain but
it's a little bit shy of
it, it's on a female fly.
But it's unilateral
over a good part of it,
misses some aspects, you know, too much on
the optic lobe, missing the parts below
which are associated with
feeding and appetite.
But a lot of modules are in there,
the central complex, which is a sort of
an internal compass for the fly
and people are studying
that independently,
olfactory learning and the mushroom body,
lateral horns, all these
names are dear to biologists
studying different parts of the fly brain.
And here's what that looks like.
That big round circle, the doughnut
that you saw, that's the ellipsoid body.
And that's associated with its navigation,
sort of an internal compass of the fly.
And here we're just sort
of flying through the data
and you can just sort
of see the complexity,
here we're getting pretty
close at this resolution,
it isn't as beautiful as what Mark has
with the dedicated hi res microscope.
What we're doing right
here, as we fly in and out,
that's going across that section.
We have to make sure that section has
good enough quality that
we can match the dendrites
from one side to the other
without loss and that's critical.
And I'll just let this play a little bit.
(audience laughter)
It's amazing that this thing
self wires and it looks
so disorganized, but in the
end it really is organized.
And there are the different modules,
we're zooming back out, here you can see
the whole upper head
of the fly brain there.
Remember these are several slabs
and we're just going to go through
six of them, we have 13 altogether.
This represents about two years of imaging
that we've done, we've just
sort of completed this.
And what will come next after this,
we want to go over, try
looking at a male fly,
but doing it now in its
entirety, all the way
and that'll be a larger imaging effort.
And here we are back
to the central complex.
So what's next?
That data is not good enough by itself,
it needs some processing
and it goes off to experts,
computer science experts
who use neural nets.
And there have been a lot
of fascinating developments
in the past few years of what they can,
how quickly they can extract it.
So they are now maybe at the level where
instead of taking 10
times longer than imaging,
they might almost be able to keep up
and pull out the nerves and
get these connectivity diagrams
of what nerve connects to
what out of the thousands,
hundreds of thousands of
different nerves in there.
And give those to biologists
so that can be correlated
with all of the other
information that they work with.
So I'd like to put this technology,
this FIB SEM, on a
little diagram like this,
just to show where it might
fit in into the world.
The bottom axis is size, we're looking at
relatively larger size structures,
it's getting close to a millimeter,
a little bit below
that, for the fly brain.
And the vertical axis is resolution.
There's some techniques out
there, as Mark talked about,
which can get much better resolution,
but the size is going to be
a little bit more limited.
And we're playing this trade off between
size and resolution
and I think FIB SEM has
a little bit of a sweet spot and fly brain
sort of demands some of those attributes.
Now the FIB SEM can also be used for,
in a different modality, where you can
operate it with lower current.
And in there one might be able to image,
let's say a whole cell,
with high resolution.
The whole cell's smaller in volume
with a higher resolution
and images instead of
being blurry like this,
can be somewhat crisper.
And we can see more detail of the synapse
in the bottom slide over
here, like right down here.
Post synaptic vesicles over here,
individual ribosomes can be imaged
and at the top we can
even see microtubules.
This is just a random
piece of mammalian cortex.
And one can take out a part of that,
segment it, similar to
what Mark has shown,
and you can get all the
intercellular organelles,
endoplasmic reticula, the mitochondria
and mine it for, you
know, for various details.
Or at the bottom maybe even
label all the vesicles,
you know, it's a little
bit up to the biologist
how they begin to mine this kind
of information, but it is accessible.
So where do we go from here?
I think next, you know, we'll continue
on trying to acquire the fly brain atlas,
that's going to be a little
bit of a longer term effort.
And, you know, that'll be then combined
with all the neural processing,
you know, to get the synaptic details
and the connectivity diagram and then
that'll be absorbed by
other scientists to,
with light imaging and behavior to
really understand the circuitry.
I think going on to the
next level beyond that,
after we have one nice, complete brain,
you begin to look at differences.
And I think this will be
another exciting phase
for this field, where we look
at fly to fly difference.
In the semiconductor
industry if you want to do
failure analysis, you do die to die,
two computer chips, take two images,
subtract them from another,
if there's a difference
that's an error, you throw it out,
or you know where the problem is.
Here we have to do a
similar version, fly to fly.
And so and the differences could be
in development stage,
not being overwhelmed
by all the background,
or is there experience,
is there a memory, can we pull it out,
is it going to be represented
in this EM data or not?
But I think it'll be just,
you know, a fascinating time.
Thanks for your attention.
(applause)
(techno music)